bush planea instalar un barandal
alrededor de una pista de patinaje la
pista de patinaje es un rectángulo de 40
metros por 20 metros cuántos metros de
baranda necesita gusto
bien aquí tenemos todo lo que
necesitamos sobre la pista de patinaje
sabemos que es un rectángulo de 40
metros de 40 metros por 20 metros por 20
metros así que qué te parece si
dibujamos esta pista de patinaje y tal
vez eso nos ayude a visualizar mejor
este problema supongamos que esta es mi
pista de patinaje entonces sabemos que
su lado más largo mide 40 metros voy a
anotar los 40 metros y su lado más corto
mide 20 metros así que también lo voy a
poner aquí 20
entonces bus en definitiva tiene que
poner barandal alrededor de estos 40
metros y después alrededor de estos 20
metros pero eso no es suficiente ya que
si alguien no sabe patinar tengo grandes
esperanzas de que google pondrá barandal
también en este lado y también en este
otro lado bus tiene que poner barandal
en todo el camino que hay en el borde o
podemos llamarlo el perímetro de esta
figura de este rectángulo tiene que
poner barandal en toda la distancia que
tiene el contorno alrededor del exterior
y ya que sabemos que la pista de
patinaje es un rectángulo entonces
sabemos que los lados opuestos son
iguales es decir que si este lado de
aquí mide 40 metros por lo tanto este
otro lado también debe de medir 40
metros y lo voy a notar este lado
a 40 metros y pasa lo mismo con este
lado si sabemos que este lado mide 20
metros entonces este lado también debe
de medir 20 metros porque es el lado
opuesto
ahora ya con esto podemos averiguar la
cantidad total de barandal que
necesitamos la cantidad de metros de
barandal que nos necesita comprar para
rodear esta pista de patinaje y bueno
primero para este lado de aquí déjame
ponerlo con este color para este lado de
aquí
wood necesita 40 metros así que lo voy a
poner aquí 40 metros ya esto le vamos a
sumar la longitud de este lado que va
hacia abajo así que para bordear este
lado bus necesitará comprar otros 20
metros de barandal
20 metros
ahora para ir en la parte inferior está
parte inferior que tengo justo aquí va a
necesitar comprar 40 metros más de
barandal así que lo voy a poner aquí
otros 40 metros y bueno ahora para
bordear estos últimos 20 metros que van
hacia arriba estos que tenemos aquí bus
necesita comprar otros 20 metros de
barandal otros 20 metros de barandal
entonces podemos sumar estos números
para encontrar la cantidad total que
necesitamos y bueno si observas 40 más
20 eso es lo mismo que 60 muy bien y si
estos 60 le sumamos los siguientes 40
bueno 60 más 40 es 100 y si a 100 le
sumamos los últimos 20 bueno 100 más 20
es lo mismo que 120 120 metros necesita
comprar bus de barandal entonces para
rodear toda esta pista de patinaje con
el barandal
woods necesita comprar o dicho de otra
manera el perímetro de toda esta pista
de patinaje va a ser lo mismo que 120
metros de barandal y acabamos